well how did you cast the in this show
it's a young boy he's about what 12 he
plays you you're 12.
so how did you get did you look at
thousands you just have like half a
dozen i just let michael jackson do it
man really again
i said what you feeling michael is that
one right there
but they test me coming in i you know
i'm vaccinating them two shots rock
that's what they call me that's what i'm
trying to say you know and you know
besides this
little foot growing out my ass i feel
fine
you don't even notice it you don't even
know yeah it's just a tiny foot growing
out my ass
when you're doing comedy you will use
language and phrases i know you did a
whole section on the show a way back
about uh how you don't like you you're a
black person but you don't like [ __ ]
you refer to people as [ __ ] uh yeah
now are you calling me a [ __ ]
did that cause problems for you
no one cares about missing men
he's like when a man's missing nobody
can't a kid's missing amber alert men
it's like bob didn't come home last
night
[Music]
[Applause]
is it or would it ever be okay for a
white person to use the word that tom
was signing around early on
the the n word well you know tom calls
me my [ __ ] all the time
because in the book that when she
becomes a vampire she then becomes sort
of like even more beautiful yes that's
what happens when you die
every time i go to a woman's funeral i
want to have sex with the car
it's the makeup
like you have to do you have to know all
the movies i've watched some of them you
know some of them
any clunkers anything you like you don't
like that you know
they're good there's some good ones yeah
yeah what are you trying to get me to
say man
any clunk
that goes without saying but anything
anything
hey you did a movie too i don't i know i
i know i did a lot went straight to
audio
i really like to fight for jobs i hate
the feeling of suddenly being like oh
well you know kristin can have it
because she'll
just because she can i i you know what i
mean
i don't know what the hell you're
talking
give me the job
i don't care if everybody's better than
me
what do you know about men that a less
attractive woman wouldn't know about men
because you cuz you get them all coming
off
all the time guys is the answer that i
don't know
what do you
what do you know about less attractive
uh i know i know i know a lot of [ __ ]
i know nobody talked to me when i was
broke
you know i skipped the line too to get
my vaccine i didn't care oh you did oh
yeah
i use my celebrity jimmy
you just did this yeah i didn't care i
was like hey step aside betty white i
didn't
step beside old people
you didn't kiss my ass
i had a cop pulled me up the other day
scared me so bad made me think i stole
my own car
get out the car you stole this car life
hey maybe i did
and this girl comes up to eddie and goes
eddie murphy i love you so much it's a
white girl i've never kissed a black man
in my life can i please kiss you
please just i just want to be able to
say i kiss the black man and eddie goes
okay okay let me let's get this straight
you you can't start at the top you got
to kiss some of these broke [ __ ] first
james how you doing what the hell
happened to your voice
it's just it's just gone what the hell
you sound like an old ass man dave
at my age the warranty begins to run out
yeah i don't know
things going bad huh
and people say well do you feel all
right otherwise no i feel like hell
other way damn man and you're still
doing the show well more or less
i don't know i don't know that it would
hold up in court oh
you you're a rich man you could just go
home
wife's no mad at you
and the last thing i need is to lose
another job to kevin hart okay
i don't need that
kev kev right there can make movies fast
every month
porno stars don't make movies that fast
you know my favorite oprah i remember
one time i was watching oprah right i'm
going to tell us and uh the show was
about secrets and this woman had to tell
her husband that she spent three hundred
thousand dollars
and they said all his money got worked
at ups and oprah's like do you have
something to tell your husband and she
said i spent 300 000
and we're gonna lose the house on
tuesday and the guy
was starting to cry and by the end of
the show it was all the guy's fault
it was amazing
oh man he was apologizing for not loving
her enough
it's the greatest oprah of all time
like your looks have helped you out
throughout your life a lot of women
always say that they don't want to be
judged by the looks and be judged by who
they are
inside
right
yeah
do you yeah
no no
not at all
no i don't know i am
this is a very strange interview you're
asking me all these because i'm
literally i'm not trying to sound like
jay leno i'm trying to you know
against the reason i'm wrong
i'm not you know trying you know because
most of the times you on the show and
they just talk about your titties or
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
well yes they they saved me a seat i
came like six shows after uh yeah yeah
yeah because they needed another black
guy
yeah
you thought i was no spade thought i was
black everybody thought you were black i
know back in the day
we got in the locker room
really not bad so it's a tv we got
excellence in movies too
a lot of excellent black movies man and
some of them don't even have kevin
hartner
there are movies kevin hart's in
everything
my man
is in
every
movie there is i think i see kevin and
sometimes he in the trailer and not in
the movie
so i saw him in magnificent kevin hart
angelina joe leaves he was playing a
bush i was like
is that ken
get out of here kevin and transformers
like it turned into a prius says i love
a cam
look at kev
first of all two kids are easier than
one
they can play in the park you read the
paper hey get off my hair
yeah i have none at all yeah
what does your mother think of your
success my mother just you know you know
what's the cool thing about growing up
in a bad neighborhood what anything you
choose to do is cool
just do something right this is the fact
that oh you want to go to work
not on crack you my boy
he is uh you know people always go how'd
you get sam he did you a favor no we got
sam a check okay
he played my dad and it was great he's
kind of method so he insisted on
sleeping with my mother that's not true
that's not that is not true at all
my dream was to be the president of the
united states i told my mother and she's
like you better not you get shot
from then on i never tried to be good in
school at all
i can't be president but what's the
point
evidently obama's mother did not say
that
now i'm older i'm 40 right uh you know
what 40 40 is old the only time
i'll be referred to only time 40 is
young is if you die at 40 right or if
you're you're sleeping with cher
it is fun just to be around this guy's
funniest guy no hardest worker i know
let me next to michael straham i mean
thank you thank you thank you chris
[Laughter]
michael walks down the street his
garbage man like get some rest
i can't wait till they have the awards
awards that's yeah yeah
they get they get you know it's weird
like everybody cares about the oscars
and it's a great thing and people don't
get oscars and they're going to cry and
they're going to be happy but the awards
don't really
affect anybody's lives in the crowd
meanwhile the nobel peace prize there's
no one there you're like yeah you just
you get a spot right in front of the
building the day of the nobel peace
prize
you got to think of the mail
nobody cares what the scientists are
wearing
what are you wearing professor allen
pants
no matter what i do that my kids are
like rich kids and i've never liked rich
kids
so there's a part of me that actually
hates my own children
deep down inside i'm like you lucky
bastard
michael jackson oh god you know all
comedians should send michael jackson a
check you know
ultimately if she knows three if you
give your agent 10 michaels you get
three at least right three percent i
always wondered does mike when michael
jackson goes to a park does he like send
balloons over to a kid or something like
you know the king of pop would like to
meet you
you see michael
michaels
waving
now what about uh
sarah the governor of alaska sarah palin
now that was sort of a surprise is
unbelievable
have you been to alaska no i've never
been
it's like the road warrior with snow
really
bleak a little crazy up there man
insane
and she's shooting mooses and she got
the moose
holding a dead bloody moose
michael vick's like why am i in jail
[Applause]
no i mean my dad was there until uh he
died then he left
i mean he'd drop in every now and then
from the death yeah
man death is crazy i gotta go
but uh
but it's okay guys i'm good yeah
daddy is like oh his father's dead
yours is going to die too